>> Larry: PEOPLE SAY THEY
DON'T KNOW ANY MUSLIMS BUT
ACTUALLY THERE ARE A LOT OF
CELEBRITIES OUT THERE WHO ARE
MUSLIM AND ARE PROUD TO BE.
TONIGHT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A
SPECIAL GAME CALLED "MUSLIM OR
NOT A MUSLIM."
WHEN THE POLICE ASK YOU TO PLAY
THIS GAME, YOU DON'T HAVE TO
ANSWER.
BUT ON "THE NIGHTLY SHOW," IT'S
A LOT OF FUN.
LET'S TRY THIS.
WHOEVER GETS THE LEAST AMOUNT OF
POINTS, THEY'LL BE THE MOST
ISLAMOPHOBIC
HOW ABOUT THAT?
WE'RE START, DEAN, IS HE MUSLIM?
>> HE IS, AND HIS REAL NAME IS
YAZIN-- HE CHANGED HIS NAME BACK
TO HIS MUSLIM NAME.
>> Larry: YOU'RE RIGHT.
YOU GET A POINT.
SHENAZ?
>> NOT A MUSLIM?
MUSLIM?
I DON'T KNOW.
>> Larry: NO, HE'S NOT A
MUSLIM.
BUT JERMAINE JACKSON IS.
VERY GOOD.
THIS IS FOR REGGIE.
MUSLIM OR NOT A MUSLIM?
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
>> WAIT, I THINK-- HAVE I SEEN
THAT GUY?
>> Larry: MUSLIM OR NOT A
MUSLIM.
>> NOT A MUSLIM.